another Russian missile strike on a
residential neighborhood in eastern
Ukraine at least one person was killed
as it hit at breakfast time
the resident gingily picked her way
through the rubble looking for anything
she can save the contents of her home
strewn across the street
slowly the most elderly were helped from
The Battered buildings
Bendix moving in to dress wounds and
inspect her injuries her hands were
nastily burned
even as we filmed the air raid siren
started again crematosk is regularly
attacked but it's no less of a shock to
those who still live here
[Music]
family now have been bombed out of their
apartment
big explosion here you can see these
buildings
big explosion in in into this section
here that's all collapsed and and over
here where's the the main strike point
was point of the matter is
virtually nowhere in this area is safe
anymore sometimes are much worse than
others we're relatively long way from
the front lines here but everywhere is
in range
and every day people are losing their
homes and pretty much everything
the Ukrainian defense of the East and in
particular the city of bakmut is now the
center of the government's strategy the
whole area is now an enormous military
zone troops piling in to join the back
move defense
and this is what it looks like inside
they're fighting house to house
these Ukrainian soldiers are under
attack they filmed their defense
RPG firing Soldier moving from side to
side of the home putting down fire
casualty rates here are horrendous for
both sides
a team of soldiers are greeted by
volunteers who have brought them some
supplies they just got out of back moot
to make this Supply run it's Grim inside
they say
more units are being brought in from all
over the country to fight will Ukraine
win I asked foreign
[Music]
military analysts are questioning the
Ukrainian tactic of slugging it out with
the Russians but President zielinski
says it's a must
civilians who've decided to stay can
only wait and watch and hope that soon
it comes to an end
Stuart Ramsey Sky News eastern Ukraine